you guys it's been a crazy week in
america
so let's find out what happened now
the big news of course is that late last
night
president trump tested positive for the
coronavirus
now i joke a lot about trump but i just
want to say that the coronavirus
is very serious this is a flu this is
like a flu
it's unfair that trump caught it because
he's always taken the virus very
seriously
this is the new hoax and he's taken
every precaution
the cdc is advising the use of
non-medical
cloth face covering this is voluntary
i don't think i'm going to be doing it
and what must make this
even scarier for him is that we don't
know when this pandemic will end
a lot of people think that goes away in
april with the heat it's going to
disappear one day it's like a miracle
so we just want to take a moment to say
how unfair it is that this happened to
him
and to the 7.31 million other americans
who've caught this virus
and that we hope he gets well soon this
is going to go away without a vaccine
now that was some very big news but it
wasn't the only news this week
nasa this week launched a spacecraft
that will deliver supplies to the
international space station
including a new toilet when asked who
broke the old toilet both astronauts
said
that's him
[Laughter]
we got to buy the rights to this toilet
store everybody makes this movie
get those millions of dollars um
please don't come see that movie
according to new research
american women over 30 have increased
their alcohol intake
by 17 during the pandemic but
anyone with one of these signs in their
house is now a full-blown alcoholic
sorry ashley i shouldn't have said her
real name she'll be fine
multiple 9-1-1 systems were temporarily
down across the country on monday
leaving residents unable to call the
number
the problem was reported by a white
woman next to a lemonade stand
and but she's probably going this has
too much sugar in it
and finally chocolate milk day was this
week
so please take a moment to say thank you
to brown cows
tick did you like that monologue i did
it likes you too
yeah hey let's take a break from the
news and talk about you for a minute t
okay tarek what did you do this weekend
did you get up to anything fun
yes actually i had a crazy weekend
i received a mysterious letter in the
mail from a man inviting me to dinner at
his mansion in the city
interestingly enough i thought who has a
mansion in new york city
so of course i went to go see it he
welcomed me and
invited me to a fine three-course meal
along with some other guests
everyone sat there silently
eating their food i didn't want to be
weird so i started to eat too
it was delicious truly one of the best
meals i've ever eaten
and i began to notice little bits of
things that didn't belong there
a drop of blood the rough skin of a
kneecap
an entire hand clutching knicks tickets
was then i realized that i was eating
human
when i realized this i was horrified the
horrifying thing
wasn't that i ate him it was that i
actually
loved it and when i realized this
i realized there was only one thing i
could do i had to
i watched monk on dvd
what i don't actually care what you were
doing i just wanted you to turn around
and ask what i did so i could tell you
about
my exciting weekend i watched two whole
seasons of monk on dvd
special features and everything oh
also you shouldn't go to strangers
houses for dinner tarek
good point we're in a pandemic be more
responsible
[Music]
you